bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono quali jaime ed oggi siamo
sulla challenge mettiamola così perché
non so come chiamare questo scempio per
i 3 milioni di iscritti tempo fa quando
avevo 15 mila iscritti non mi ricordo
più
avevo fatto uno speciale dove su happy
meals ogni volta che morivo mi mangiamo
un cucchiaio di nutella per non ripetere
la stessa challenge ogni volta che
sbaglierò non dovrà assaggiare la
nutella ma dovrò fare un'altra cosa
peggiore qui con me c'è giorgio che lo
aiuterà a morire si la sfida consiste
nell ogni morte assaggiare uno shock
piccante e quindi mio amico giorgio fuà
presente serve per ce l'hai l'estintore
bene sono perché sono sabrina un cazzo
difficoltà dei livelli semplice faccia
iniziamo con uno semplice rock swing era
sì sono difficili va via dai proviamoci
edi è di stai calmo ed aspetta non mi
faccio lo faccio per capire come si
gioca
quando quando si sta a casa grande mi
sta cagando queste dovessi morire
davvero è bruttissimo ed io non mi far
stronzate è brutto deficiente no no no
sei un deficiente una cosa dico ma vabbè
ma l'hai messo troppo giocano metti in
bocca
cosa la faccio io facendo
porca [ __ ] joy piccantissima jo jo è
piccolissimo da miracolo un giorno
miracoli uomo e corri corri corri
piccantissima joe porca [ __ ] già
veloce e altra stanza
ti senti vivo in culo per tantissimo a
questo video finisce qua
come al solito si è visto è piaciuto
lasciando argomento mi piace bastarda
maxi yacht conto cazzona iniziali di
salsa piccante era orribile quando
abbiamo deciso di fare sta stronzata
neanche in social facebook sono ste cose
a [ __ ] è di ti prego non morire
questo accanto a rosso forte vai piano
che [ __ ] o vito ho vinto sono morto
ma wint allora ruba gioiello questo e
non è semplice ma è fattibile ma guardo
ma non è di mettere così tanto e troppo
tra faccio giovane troppo sono astemio
io non ce la faccio a non ce la faccio
già non ce la faccio non ce la faccio
questo mi sembra silente quanto bene il
coso degli horcrux
ma come fa a essere così piccante cosa
cazzo ci mettono dentro dinamite ma
possiamo cambiare tipo challenger
facciamo cervi baldi charlie la nutella
dai la nutella era bello cambiamo la
challenge a metà prossimo con in tempo
quello che sta diventando tragica
situazione arriva arriva arriva
[Musica]
è un appena degli infetti giuro è un
girone dell'inferno è bruttissimo è la
cosa più che io abbia mai fatto in vita
mia preferisco farmi frustare a sangue
da da godzilla dammi dell'acqua è
orribile non ce la posso fare a mesi
minigames questo meglio questo e cioè
spero mini di lì per vincere devo
beccare il papà di you ok ho vinto
mika salo andato sulla morte forte c'è
un tizio successo perché è sarò io dopo
questo video è a [ __ ] fa chi è nono
spy phone o lo stato sarà fidatissimo
male sono i nato male ok ok è andata
benissimo che era facile 91 e non a lei
era facile cazzo e di genere sono
orribili ne vinco mai nice one quanto
deve durare st livello de fútbol non mi
piace il nome di statista palla perché
sono tutti i dieci in amici cos'è sta
roba sport 2
ero vivo e rovigo è non so come krasic
rusher questo mi sembra is it easy c'è
scritto easy lo faccio lo faccio su un
carico parker è morto liu che va bene no
ora vabbè ma c'è più di mezzo porca eva
se gli ultimi fi uccidere da marzo
quanto sono scordinato a vita sono vivo
solo da soli non ce la posso fare
porca eva dai ma non si può fare sta
cosa dai non si poteva fare non vale non
posso fare un altro tentativo non fare
come bambini che non vogliono e la
verdura quanti problemi ai mieli nervoso
dell'arma piccanti non la sopporto mi
chiudo il naso aiuta se davvero non è
vero bastardo non è vero da acqua di chi
morì dopo questo video il karma ti verrà
prendere roba loro
questo mi sembra semplice posso cambiare
livelli che questa merda giò senti io
sto scegliendo dei livelli del cazzo
fammi di fare una volta ti prego hai una
v una vita una guida una vita senza
sbagliato sveglia perché di canalizzare
giura giura poi poi lo faccio giuro è
l'ultima possibilità
[Musica]
tu sai quante difficile che può far
ingoiare c'è quel gusto di lai zitto
totalmente morendo che mi fa male ma non
importa c'è intanto sto morendo uguale
quindi non ho più sensibilità non so
come spiegarlo basta cambiamo basta
jager lover siamo studi aiger lower game
che è più easy patto patto prima di
cominciare pad siccome di either lover è
più easy questa volta facciamo una volta
a testa
ok va be the shoes anche redemption
contro leonardo da vinci leonardo da
vinci e fino leonardo da vinci contro
miley cyrus e credo sia miley cyrus è
fino miley cyrus con sono incinta mari
science si semmai di said sono incinta
non tradirebbe radiohead dichiara ghazi
mi sto pagando ma radio ed contro
fallout coatto che avesse difficile
fallout fallout visa visa attimo
qualcosa come 47 milioni
smetti ti ho detto che no non è
possibile non è la mia vita è una
menzogna è stato cappello gioco in cui
giocare subito loreti sto chiamando col
mio nome
penso a quanto questa merda fa ma
aspetta una t buy un'amicizia live aid
toccate va devi morirci in questo gioco
ma che cazzo coachella vento a cella
porca [ __ ] un consiglio a cena manco
fossimo a cascella mentre mauri cardi
piscia mi faccio la sua pesca nella
nostra chiesta tipo venus williams mica
la campionessa di tennis mancato di più
la campionessa undertaker secondo me lui
omofobo come undertaker più c'è una
fobia avatar
li avrei messo undertaker di più ma
vedremo non mi ama tanto
casa prova salsa divise sono scemo io
l'avevo detto che non era così e pensa
che io ne ho fatti quattro se il tuo
primo [ __ ] a george orwell o
chanel chanel totti sull'occhio di
giorgio incredibile hpa vietnam non
perder
hp ma fammi heidegger similare mezzo per
il 20 o ri assolutamente no non è vero
come possibile di viventi
insomma una cosa troppo gay ed ha
abbondanato acate va fatta ma che
connubio olocausto e cene io mi devo
riprendere solo al cinema
minchia 16 milioni marcata solo perché
l'ho nominato nell'altro io mi chiamo
questa difficilissima
questa questa è limits qua ti voglio
seconda non ci può avere secondo me
vincendo me no ma porca eva malcelato
era santo orange già tipo 20 milioni
mica sto facendo in 18 e battere il mio
record del primo ballo che cosa sheva è
una compagnia telefonica da aimi che
odio che di pizzi tutto giù per di rosi
io non vado chiuso i ragazzi non solo
facciamo forte o non sto guardando ad
occhi chiusi mi fido
basta ma sei scemo
[Applauso]
e io concludere quel video una è stata
una sicuramente un po più stronzo della
della nutella challenger avevo fatto per
i 15.000 grazie quindi ragazzi spero che
ai video vi sia piaciuto
dopo dagli dopo ti porta minio quindi
ragazzi servi dove è piaciuto ma sento
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e camillo totale
schizzi che non siete ancora iscritti
iscriversi ci si siede e noi ci vediamo
un prossimo video al volo dai ragazzi di
punta ma dove vai ad affrontare vi verrà
ragazzi bene devi puntare centro centro